[Music]
you were nominated for an Emmy last year
yeah okay for getting on which by the
way is a such a brilliant show you're so
great in it right
did you enjoy going to the Emmys did you
have a good time
well I have to tell you for me Emmys was
the best date night ever
now I did not win they called Allison
Janney's name and I wanted to be mad but
I freaking love Allison Janney sorry I
couldn't get mad because I was like
she's brilliant but my husband leaned
over right after they you know they call
it a different name and he says you do
know that you will always be my leading
lady don't you let me tell you what I
was really clapping for because in his
tuxedo my husband almost got into a
fight that night what yes gotta go fight
at the MGM in a tuxedo yes okay here we
go people that carpet was hot as fish
grease you know how hot it is really hot
yeah sweltering with the heat of
injustice and oppression yeah so we go
inside he goes let me get you a
champagne and I go great these two guys
come up and they're like hey we want to
get a picture and they start jostling me
off in a little aggressive
they were so inappropriate and
aggressive and then my husband walks up
and he goes hey what's going on and the
guy goes calm down brother
we're just trying to get a picture you
said I'm nacho dam brother that's my
wife
get your hands off my wife and I said oh
my god if you fight right now you are
definitely getting some when I get home
Wow so that's a secret huh I didn't know
that I didn't know that I just like that
he was just so aggressive and it was two
of them and he still was willing to
protect me so I felt yeah so so it was a
good night it was a great night
yeah
you